gentlemen you had talked about in a
prior interview staying true to your
content but also working with brands and
incorporating that into your content no
you have a very successful YouTube
channel and I'm wondering what your
thoughts are and what your advice is to
other Creators on staying true to your
brand being able to make a lifestyle
from doing the videos but also
incorporating paid sponsorship I think
brands are actually kind of cool now a
lot cooler than they used to be I think
that they're friendly getting the
content creation element to it so as
long as the creators are staying true to
their content and incorporating the
brand rather than highlighting the brand
or making it seem like it was just for
the brand I think is a cool approach to
do it where you can get a paycheck for
yourself you can get your production
funded and also you could work in the
brand placement and my subtle way rather
than hitting your viewers over the head
with it but ultimately just comes down
to staying true to your vision and
staying true to your followers and being
communicative with everybody that out
there that to let them know like you
know we have this coming up from the
great people of coca-cola or you know
whoever the brand is you're not making
Matthew McConaughey Lincoln commercials
but you're making you know something
that your viewers would expect you to
make and incorporating the brand that
way yeah I mean I think it's brands are
much more like the storytelling of
commercials is a much bigger thing now
than it is I feel like even you know and
in part of it I think is the evolution
that commercials are sort of
disappearing a little bit with the rise
of these kind of digital platforms
advertising is going to have to be more
brands are going to have to be naturally
more integrated into things because
there are fewer people like watching
actual you know advertisements on you
know cable TV or network TV so I think
that's part of it I also think this is
going to sound kind of brash but I think
the idea of like selling out its kind of
it's like this weird sort of I
don't know this Western idea that like
you can love you can love a creator and
then the second that they're actually
able to support themselves doing what
they do you like that makes their
creating less less interesting I think
that's
of a weird like up myth that is
like of I don't know this kind of assist
a weird creation I tonight so I think I
was necessary eggs yeah exactly it's
like why why not support the person who
Ike who finally like gets to do the
thing gets paid to do the thing that
they love to do I it's sort of a strange
relationship but if you know any brands
were looking watching this
you